i am more optimistic than ever
the more i think about the future for a
couple of reasons
reason number one
being this idea that
this present was created by people this
present was created by folks who had
dreams and imaginations and values now i
think if we stick to what we say our
values are or as dr king said if we stay
true to what we say on paper we can
really build a future that looks like
our values of opportunity
of liberty and of justice for all and
and number two i'm incredibly
optimistic about the future because for
all the ways in which the present isn't
what we want to be
sometimes i i get heartened with
thinking about
the past was even worse
like for all the ways in which
um it feels like we're moving backwards
from the very real consequences of the
roe v wade decision recently
um to the very real consequences of
getting the voting rights sack to the
very real real consequences of
attempted coups and insurrections there
was actually a time in this country
where things were worse
um
and
things only got better
because people even mired in this
function of today
did what this foundation does did what
you all do and stepped back and said
okay
but what can tomorrow be
and and also it's incredibly inspiring
because
we have the opportunity to bring other
people into that future planning process
to really speak from experience about
sort of how the future could look
different particularly for those on the
margins because the the next invention
to make our life easier
it's not
on sand hill road
in the presidio it's probably some
little kid in hunter's point breathing
environmental toxins it's probably a
young person in south stockton hearing
gunshots at night it's probably a young
person in watts i'm sleeping hungry that
that when we leave so much on the table
not just for today but for tomorrow by
allowing the mistakes in the imagination
of the past
dictate how we live in in the present
[Music]
you